all right guys bang-bang I've got the
man himself cz here thanks so much for
doing this thank you so much thanks for
having me
of course let's stir it right off how's
your back I know you had surgery yeah my
back stained quite all right now yeah
after the surgery I feel really good the
doctor says there's a little minor
complication but I don't feel it and I'm
doing physical therapy exercises and I
can walk which before was difficult for
me sitting was really hard for me so now
I can't stay I don't sit for very long
but I can stand I can so I feel pretty
good actually
but it's only been two months since the
surgery so I'm still taking it quite
lightly I'm still recovering etc so I'm
just doing the regular a smaller lighter
exercises just for a mostly physical
therapy exercises trying to recover yeah
all right we've got to make sure that
you're healthy cuz Finance is counting
on you is one with most of crypto and
let's just jump in maybe you can give us
a quick update on on Finance so I don't
know if you wanted to share kind of any
latest metrics or anything but just how
how are things go and she's lost time we
talked
so finances yeah so especially recently
with we're the numbers we're seeing are
just phenomenal so we see on jet in
general roughly about 5x more volumes
than before like since the sort of
corner virus took over so business-wise
the platform's like doing really well
so both futures now them also even even
in this environment our market shares
been gaining so futures is - features
now the very clearly number one futures
perform in the last couple weeks
so business is doing really well for us
we know there's a lot of so even other
exchanges that we hear there's I think
they're the same more traffic I think
you could be due to a number of reasons
you could be people just bored at home
nothing to do is although online
business is doing well and then you
could also be that the you know the
macroeconomic issues
without quantitative easing people
moving slowly back into crypto so it
could be an any number of those reasons
and yeah but overall business is going
well awesome it feels a lot like when
you get volatility in the traditional
markets you also see the volatility in
crypto and then that all toady leads to
trading or kind of just interest in
doing something like people don't like
to sit there when it all the prices are
moving in feel like they're not doing
anything which is obviously probably
pretty good for the business as well
yeah I mean volatility is generally good
for the change business so the for
exchanges the worst the worst is when
the market is flat so when it's flat
there's no no one's creating and when
it's volatility is there's always high
volumes but usually when it's flat at a
low price is not as good advice flat at
a higher price so when the prices are
high it's always good for the exchanges
so we so we see the price be high high
volatility is okay but generally
speaking the higher the price the better
for sure and then how has a Cove 8:19
kind of impacted I know you guys had
last time we talked 400 500 employees
kind of 40 different countries and
pretty distributed already but have you
seen any impact from the virus itself on
the Oh business so again I think on this
point I think if anything was positive
for balance because we're quite used to
so we have been working remotely pretty
much throughout the last two years and
we've quite used to it and a lot of our
internal conversations like people call
this quarantine so so I think and also
it kind of to be honest slowed down a
few of our competitors so some of our
competitors we had more centralized
offices then more to adjust sending
people home people may or may not have
the right equipment they may their team
structures and daily routines may or may
not be structured to facilitate
just working remotely right so like what
can we Maury does require different
difference in mentality a lot of
conference calls a lot of zoom
Google means a lot of other things so so
I think for us we are quite used to it
and also we've seen we've seen a lot
more flooding job applications so people
are really applying for jobs more so now
we're hiring very aggressively which was
actually difficult so sort of towards
second half of last year we were
actually try to compete with other
organisations the internet companies etc
and so but now we're actually seeing a
lot more candidates that's available in
the market so overall things are
actually things actually alright I think
given that with online remote working
type of business we're quite the
coronavirus did not impact us as
negatively as we would we would have
expected but we do we do understand
there's a lot of other people who are
sitting like a lot so that's why we kind
of gain a lot of returning work etc
yeah it's ways things where as we've
talked to you know our portfolio
hundred-plus companies what we keep
saying to them is look there's two ways
to think about what's happening right
now one you've got to have the defensive
mindset to make sure your balance sheets
strong enough to kind of survive through
whatever you know this ends up being
from an economic standpoint but to is if
you're in a good position you can
actually be hyper aggressive and
actually still on a market share and it
sounds like that's kind of the approach
you're taking here is you're in a good
position you've got a business that's
actually benefiting from a lot of the
volatility and the virus stuff and so
rather than just be defensive the whole
time you casually get aggressive and I
try to filled out and scale and in
really gain market share right now yeah
I absolutely think that way so for us I
think we had a strong balance sheet
before we have a strong revenue strong
profits we were not relying on burning
money before so we were growing like
before our limitation factor was
actually just our speed to hierarchy
people just talking into getting all the
candidates in talking with them
interviewing them and then agree on a
deal compensation etc so right now
that problems not is eased up a lot and
we're seeing business demand on the
platform growing and so we'll so I think
we're kind of unique in that way where
there's a strong balance sheet
supporting the business and that's this
is why we are very aggressive
both heart and also looking at
acquisitions etc so we're just
progressing on both fronts yeah speaking
of hiring I know a lot of executives
take different approaches to it some
want to be really involved in some
basically hire people that they trust
and they kind of take it what's your
approach to the hiring process and how
involved are you on the hiring process
on the senior heart I am involved so I
like to interview the senior hires
before I kind of do the last depending
on me for their their reporting to me
directly then I do a very in-depth
interview if they're reporting to one
somebody who is reporting to me then I
have a more casual chat but I think one
of my strengths is actually pretty I'm a
pretty good judge of character so I I
talk to them for a few minutes and I try
to figure out hey this guy passionate
about crypto is this guy a legit genuine
character does he know his stuff so on
the technical side for job for tech like
programming technology interviews I'm
pretty good like I can ask a couple of
simple questions and and get a very good
feel of where the guy is for some other
rules unless because those other rules
are not my background so I'm less
judging the skill sets that accurately
but then I just realized that I'm on the
team for I rely on the team for that but
I do talk with the candidate to just get
a feel off the prismatic match culture
match etc so so I think I have a pretty
good feel for just interacting with
people even though I may not may or may
not know the technical expertise so I do
I do get involved in the senior hires
but we hire so many people that there's
a lot of guys I'm not mad I don't even
know that yeah absolutely
in I guess this then leads to like
there's so much going on right and I
think one of the kind of the resounding
messages I hear from CEOs right now is
hey we've got are just normal business
operations that we've got to worry about
make sure our business is strong and
then you layer in the virus stuff and
there's kind of this health crisis so I
want to make sure that my team is
healthy their families are healthy etc
but that health crisis the response
globally is now creating this economic
crisis right where you see the macro
economy kind of slowing down maybe just
share your thoughts on what you're
seeing of anah macro economy are you
worried about anything there and kind of
how you're thinking through
more of kind of a response to the virus
more so than just that virus itself sure
I think there's a yeah so that's a
pretty so this there's a lot of aspects
to it I think for the for the balanced
team we do we have asked the balanced
team to work from home way early like so
when this thing is kind of brewing in
China I just told everyone I said look
justjust work from home and so I think
that was like end of January early
February I just said let's just work
from home so and our team is pretty used
to it seems like they sometimes
congregate you know coffee shop or stuff
like that when they're in the city it's
just a less let's just be more careful
about it and and we also measure our
internal employee or the team members or
we call we don't really use the word
increased that much so I also make sure
that we have like we have supplies that
we secured through various channels and
we measure most of our team members do
have to supplies even our members right
now you we've we've shipped their
parents spies like masks where they
couldn't get them right now so we so we
took a lot of precaution to ensure
safety of our employees and we all
encourage them to work from home just
don't go out that often and they
typically work from home anyway so
they're quite like they quite the very
used to it
and at a higher level at a bigger scale
in different countries in the world I
think I think this thing's gonna last
multiple months it I think it's gonna
last I think coming summer the virus may
subside but I think we've gotta be very
careful if you look at past Atomics
there's a very often second wave come
come autumn and I think right now we
just with which we're witnessing this is
like a leadership test for a lot of
countries right so countries who are
well organized even like if you look at
China even though you happen earlier
there but they actually had a I think
the numbers may be too low I'm like the
numbers may or may not be accurate but
the situation is that you have it under
control
most most guys are returning to normal
the work is returning to normal
other countries are still
and other countries are still losing the
battle with it to be honest especially
like America I think the numbers the
numbers the numbers say the results of
the results are there so I think the
mystery at the red pop stage where we
haven't we haven't seen the plateau so
that's very worrying and I think that
would definitely have an economic effect
I think we're back in February March
people in some countries or including
the United States some people are saying
oh no this thing's just happening impact
in China and nothing swing by the US
I think we're living one global economy
there's no escape so I think we're
seeing that playing out I think it's
gonna be multiple amounts it's going to
have very severe impact on the economy
on jobs etc so I think we've got to
prepare this for the long run and
afterwards I also think even like after
a few months after this passes we're
gonna see a new economy so things gonna
be different people are people will be
the social norms are gonna be different
so I don't know how different you will
be but I think in the back of people's
heads people will I think even come
autumn or or the next winter people will
be very cautious about this thing Japan
it depends on whether we we discover a
vaccine or not so all of those things
play a factor but most countries are
banning travel I think travels gone for
the next I don't know half a year or so
to a large extent so travel within the
country may be allowed but I think
people are very cautious about it
even today so there's a lot of
restaurants are being hit really hard
movies or theaters would be really hard
so I think a lot of businesses will
change but also in this turbulent
environment there's a lot more
opportunities right so when when one
business unfortunately when one business
goes down other business that's right so
I think online businesses will do well
international business the virtual
aspect of the cryptocurrencies actually
helps a lot
I think cryptocurrency is gonna see a
fairly strong boost to be honest
combined was like quantitative easing
depression like cut the countries have
no other option but you'd print a lot of
money
now and that's gonna those money right
now it's not free flowing into the
economy but once they start flowing cost
of goods most prices are gonna go up
very dramatically and I think
cryptocurrency will go up much more like
um proportionally higher so yeah so I
think all of those things gonna happen
and I think people in the crypto
industry are generally in a very good
spot so I think we just got a I think we
want to we want to work really hard I
think it's actually important to work
really hard in this economic to be
turbulent times because there are new
opportunities and the guys who can grab
these new opportunities are much there's
much more new opportunities
opportunities right now than they were
before I also think most likely more
banks and more financial institutions
are gonna look at cryptocurrency
they're more willing to work with a
crypto currency exchanges payment
services etc so I think there's a lot of
opportunity it's not gonna be easy it's
gonna be tough but yeah you know when
when the going gets tough the tough gets
going yeah it's really interesting
because on the economic side one of the
things that people I think are missing
is just like the economy is not gonna
recover and call people are allowed to
leave their home right I mean it's just
what are you gonna do from your house
you basically are gonna pretty much you
can do things in crypto maybe you'll buy
some things online but most of your
economic activity is gonna go to zero
and so you just can't get an economy
back if everyone sitting at home which i
think is uh kind of a missing point cuz
there's a lot of people who say oh this
is a two-week thing and it's like I
don't think that this is two weeks no
he's not two weeks so in the ideal world
if that word it if the world is really
really well organized and we say look
let's agree to stay home everyone stays
home for two weeks and whoever have some
things go to the hospital whoever it
doesn't then are done
yes but ideal world yes but humans are
not organized that way and we're very
we're seeing very poor leadership across
different countries right so if
everybody studied lock down the end of
January for three weeks or four weeks
we're done and very very few number of
people will get sick but people don't
act that way
so yeah yeah we'll see let's switch
gears you were you recently announced a
pretty big purchase while everyone else
is running around
and worried about surviving you guys
announced that you're purchasing coin
market cap maybe just talk a little bit
about kind of how that deal came
together how you originally met them and
then kind of what the logic behind the
acquisition is sure so I've known
Brandon I've used McCoy market caps for
like I don't know ever like from 2013-14
when they started back then there was
like a number of our like sort of data
aggregators but they claimed market cap
just grew grown to be the most popular
one by far so and I so when we staffed
er we started it was like basically
about two years ago I was just sort of
paying Brandon just sort of very very
occasionally not frequently just sort of
hey how you doing what etc so I mean
I've been paying him overtime with with
a sort of interest of st. potentially
working together more across a
partnership or potentially in the
acquisition I didn't sort of mention in
that terms I was just sort of like I was
just trying to understand what his
mental mentalities are and it was really
towards in the end of last year like a
few months ago we we we met again and we
kind of discussed and we both felt there
was an interest and so we we talked we
like I think we met over we met twice
and we sort of discussed the numbers and
we came to a term pretty pretty quickly
and it was very simple it was a very
simple deal so it's like there's no
complicated stuff going on and and then
from there we're just like getting
lawyers to execute the deal which took a
while but and none of us went back like
none of us thought about to renegotiate
the terms of the deal even in this
economic turbulent times I think like
for me I'm looking at this thing at a
very very long term play it's not like
okay how much is it worth today or
tomorrow or the day the day before so we
don't think in that kind of terms where
I think look if we right now is what I
think is one of the most valuable as
platforms in the industry and I think
we'll grow another 10x 100x so I also I
think the higher
value for that is not you make it just
service finance not complex change I
think she continued to growth or what
its original purpose providing data
access for Krypton and beat the landing
page of crypto have information on there
so I think which coin market have will
continue to grow in that way and I
actually think that they have not been
expanding super aggressively because
it's a small team they've been growing
organically the selling ads etc right
look by working with finance we acquired
and we also have we also have more room
to found it so I think we just want to
continue to fund the growth of it this
naturally a lot of synergies with - calm
but we're not there's also naturally a
lot of synergies with every other
exchange out there so coin market cap
what continue to maintain neutrality and
independence and any other exchange who
wants to continue to work with them I
think most of moment it definitely well
because they are by far the largest
single referral for any exchange so I
think and they will continue to work
with our biggest changes so that's fine
so that's kind of how the deal was went
together you actually pretty simple got
it in terms of kind of we care about
this 10x 100x expansion like what is
your vision at least of comeback path
like how do you actually 10x that is
that let's take the BAI Nance playbook
of kind of super aggressive growth and
just sense of of our folks over and help
them do that or is there something else
that's a little bit more complex and how
you do it sure I think I actually thinks
it's actually something much more
simpler I think we just gotta wait for
the market I think basically in the
market grow then likely for Kony market
have to go 10x or even for Bannister go
10x I think likely market caps by far
the largest data aggregator or and then
I provide our site and - comm is my
swarm the largest exchanges and both in
futures spot marketing so so I think but
like even if you kill all the other
industry pairs we're now gonna go we're
not gonna go another I don't know 10x or
net definite
100x so I think the goal is definitely
to yeah we we both like we're definitely
over like 10 percent market share you
know a lot of places so we we don't have
room to grow 10x even make sure
everybody in those things so I think the
goal is to is to make the industry
bigger and and to make the industry
bigger we actually can't grow alone we
actually want to grow with other
industry players so we want other
exchanges to grow we want other better
data providers to grow information
providers to grow because this is like
100 or 200 different countries in the
world and a lot of different geographies
different cultures a lot of different
banking channels Fiat channels etc
there's only so much we can do ourselves
even though we're the bigger we're warm
the biggest fairs in the market but we
need to grow the industry bigger we need
other people to do it with us so I think
right now if you look at the industry
probably only wine wine 1000 people have
crypto so this at least a thousand times
to grow but and even that is not a very
good measurement I think if you like if
you jerks the potential market share of
taxi or the the market size of taxis for
uber that's not the potential market
size and they're gonna expand our market
so I think Crito in crypto we're looking
at the same same thing acquittal will be
able to serve as new business types new
opportunities that the traditional Fiat
world does not does not touch or can it
cannot service so I think basically in
my mind the trick is really just to grow
the industry so it's not so much hey
let's give them more but we would
definitely want to want them to hire
more and grow the team I think the
team's too small and but other than that
I think we're just gonna continue to
build innovative products and provide
services that other people wants to use
and hopefully the industry will grow I'm
not pretty confident the industry won't
grow yeah obviously I'm there with you
on that one of the most asked questions
I got when I ask people for questions to
ask you and obviously you don't have to
answer this if you don't want but people
want to know how was the acquisition
paid for was the cash stock or B&B and I
said look I'll ask him but I don't think
he's gonna answer that one so it's not
that I don't want to answer that part is
covered by the
so actually can't answer it but it's a
it's a pretty straightforward deal so
there's nothing too complicated about it
and and to be honest I for us doesn't
matter what the method is so if if B&B
cash is the same thing if it's cash if
this cash
B&B is cash or BTC is cash to us when
people say cash then problem in u.s.
dollars that's fine
we will come if we need that we can just
we can just sell BTC or sell be and
being converted cash to us is the same
thing to be honest and it's a very
straightforward deal there's nothing
complicated about it one of the things
that I think he you said early on that I
remember saying hey I like that guy is
you said look I got no more fiat left
right I spent it all and get all crypto
yes so but look if we have to spend fiat
then we just sell some crypto and but we
don't host yet so whatever fear we want
we need to spend we just sell crypto and
we spend it and we and then we'll have
no fear left again so that's kind of how
we operate got it one of the things that
I think you've done very differently
than especially exchanges in the United
States etc is you've made some pretty
big bets on non-us countries so
obviously India is a big one a couple of
others what are you seeing in the non-us
countries right now given the global
instability are you seeing kind of a ton
of interest into crypto are you seeing
expansion there maybe just highlight
some of that sure I can come every
country is very different u.s. is
definitely one of the most develop
economies and it's a very strong economy
so there's a lot of money Floria route
trading institutional training it's very
established and then there's a lot of
money to be made in those markets those
markets a bigger so the US accounts for
like the worst overall the worst twenty
percent twenty plus percent GDP with
only four percent of the population so
pro kappa if you reach one user and the
user program the value per user is much
higher for any business so you mean like
social media trading platforms etc so a
lot of guys of focus on those type of
markets China is a very different one
China China's getting the people is
getting relatively rich there's a lot of
rich guys with discretionary spending
power and online businesses mobile
businesses internet businesses
developed so that's another very
interesting market if you look at big
countries the regulations taste it tends
to be very expensive so you gotta have
like a team of lawyers apply for
different licenses deal with a lot of
different regulators etc and also
because the traditional financial
economy is very established that's
actually more incumbent players to that
blocks of growth of crypto so we're in
countries like say for that if you look
at Africa even India the traditionally
cut financial services are not so pretty
established there's actually more
opportunity for you to grow and India is
like the second most populous country in
terms of people in the world and it's
called 1.3 billion people and that's
there's a lot of opportunity there there
was a lot of uncertainty in terms of the
regulations and very likely we placed a
bet before that and before it was clear
and the results turn out to be favorable
but when we press the bed it wasn't
betting on the outcome of the regulatory
changes it was like that was that was
really good jean-michel leaves a really
good team they've a good products they
understand the local market and we and
we ask ourselves right so I am I gonna
be able to go to India leave it you
build a team there and compete they're
gonna be pretty difficult for me I think
I think I do have the senses to realize
where the show comes for myself or our
current teams are I understand the
different cultural norms different
business cultures different psychologic
psychologies in different markets and
different just different just every
market is very different so in markets
where we feel comfortable operating then
we we going offered ourselves markets
where we were lucky enough to meet a lot
of strong local team then we work with
the local team and also if you look at
for them a different market Africa right
it's got one point two billion people
for the whole continent is divided into
a lot of different countries but they
are the people are still people still
getting used to like smartphones and
only only 11% of the population have
bank accounts so they can actually just
skip bank and bank accounts we don't
need to bank them so with
we no longer need to back down back we
can just give them ourselves on an app
so there's a lot of different
opportunities there so I think a lot of
people focus on us and we are now - so
we have a partner there and so us is a
very important economy but it's one of
the countries in the world so we think
kryptos value is really when you connect
different countries in the world that's
where the valley really really shines so
that's kind of our approach and
philosophy
yeah are there any countries that maybe
people aren't thinking about that you're
like look I'm really excited obviously
India is a big one and you kind of you
know made some moves there but are there
other countries they you want to kind of
highlight that you think people should
be paying attention to I think almost
every country is quite interesting to be
honest India is definitely one of them a
number of countries South Africa Nigeria
Uganda those are really interesting as
well because in those countries the
internet is getting their people what do
have people the number of people having
smartphones is really increasing and
what other countries there are some like
there's some really interesting
countries as well Vietnam is really
active turkey is really active in terms
of crypto currencies so we're fairly
active there so our user base is fairly
active there there's a lot of different
countries in the world that's so and so
yeah I mean we try to build a platform
that's really neutral to was that's kind
of geography independent and is much
easier to do with just crypto to [ __ ]
it's a lot harder when you want to touch
yet but unfortunately today most of the
money if the Fiat so we still gotta go
country by country to bring them yeah
yeah it almost feels like there's the
two parallel worlds being built and I
think about it if you take the totality
of that it's at what percentage of the
total economic activity or financial
activity whatever is in crypto 1% might
be hyper aggressive right like it's very
very slow on percent and as the crypto
industry grows that will become a bigger
and bigger percent and that to me is
like one of the biggest metrics of
measuring progress it's just if you can
get to
percentage crypto 10% 20% that's where I
think we'll really really start to see
some material impact on the world
yeah I'm guessing my numbers tell me
that we're at about 21 percent really
just mind 1000 so on the positive so on
the negative side it's really tiny so
we're basically working over in a very
tiny market right now positive positive
side is like the growth potential is
really high so we just got to make sure
that and I think that growth will come
and I think the course will be sped this
when we speak a set up by this right now
all the turmoil in the current economic
environments so I'm pretty I'm pretty
confident about it I think we are in the
right industry we are we are the super
early adopters right now and we just got
agree once we go into tech 1% I think
we'll see 10x and of course 10% will see
me next
yeah for sure us you guys partnered in
brought by Nance us with Katherine to
what many people I think thinks it's one
of the most important geographies in the
world for this what's going on there and
how do you feel it's going yeah I think
us is going quite well us I think what
overall the team's my understanding is
the finest u.s. teams taking them well
very careful and a solid approach so
they're progressing in very careful
manners because there are spending a lot
of time on regulatory compliance getting
licenses etc so hopefully we they will
be able to bring to turn our additional
states very soon and at the same time
with the state's they're they're capable
serving right now they're they're
copying over more and more features from
- comm from the technology platform
products perspective so staking most
elections coins they have a very
rigorous selection process for listing
coins but I think they do have a larger
selection than the other players in in
the US and the trading fees are much
lower the trading fees is about a third
of what other platforms charge most of
you with the Rijo guys the retail gas
may or may not care too much about it
but slowly we see we've seen the shift
over
yeah I think they're just going very
steady so I think and they mark their
market is actually slowly increasing
most people may or may not understand
that or may or may not notice just yet
but I think overall things are coming
I'm very pleased with the progress - us
seen so I think just give it time the
other players have been in the market
for like I don't know eight nine years
so they are very entrenched and they're
the other the competition is high the
other platforms are very high quality
and they they get the very credible
platforms so I think that's that's good
because then they also help grow the
industry so I think by - the US or
although I'm pretty happy with the
progress yeah it's one of these
interesting things where the u.s.
specifically you have to have the
regulatory bent right you almost have to
go slow to get the approvals there's
other countries obviously where you
don't need to do that and so it kind of
had some some challenges there one of
the things that he recently announced is
this mining pool maybe talk a little bit
about you know what exactly you guys are
gonna build and kinda what the logic is
there sure I mean to be honest yes bill
it was the it was like one of the team
members said look we should build a
mining pool and this is how to do it I
said well that sounds that makes sense
so dude do you know how to do you want
to do it she says yes again he's a girl
and they just went when I hadn't and
doing and in my head or written
originally I thought it was just gonna
be a BTC mining floor but she's also
doing pew as for us so now we're kind of
having the us notes swapping votes
exchanging vows like you gotta do like I
didn't know this before you gotta change
like 21 different votes with like
different parties and all this stuff
going on like just horse trading stuff
like that so but another day the goal is
to build a both APO W like for Bitcoin
and also POS for most other coins my
name for and also to be able to support
other non mining by staking cos staking
coins as well so and so all of this are
sort of an interest interest generating
or income generating products for our
users so you can
for Bitcoin at the miners well for they
might empower it into a pool and we'll
do that and they'll get coins for
staking coins mistake number estate you
lock your number of coins and you get a
interest rate or reward also this is
from a user perspective this is very
similar to the loan product we have the
lending so you lend your product for the
margin traders and get an interest for
the for the users is the same thing and
then well we also roll another loan
business so all of that ties into what I
call plan the balance finest products
week so all of the financial products in
our platform so that that's all tying
together so they're building it I think
they're gonna the mining PO is gonna be
launched soon from what I hear but again
it's a fairly independent team the money
with it the team a couple the team
leader and a couple of the senior guys
on the team comes to me watching about
four like I don't know different budget
requests some some decisions I just
usually flip a coin if I go for this I
mean this is the magic of Finance right
it is the fact that you just find really
counted smart ambitious people put them
together and they come up with these
ideas and you basically are given the
green light and they go and they build
it and use the resources and kind of
distribution you have and actually you
know you you probably want to build it
one of the largest mining pools right
hopefully yeah I mean it's not launched
yet but typically we do have the network
effect where people who I think number
one we have the brand we have the number
of users and a lot of big miners already
trading us they mine and animals of
coins to finance and this they either
sell to be a us DT or b.a.p USD so
they're already trading with us so I
think the network effect is there and
having and also giving the network
effect all of the services we provided
we can we provide at lowest fees so if
you look at the market we always our
fees are usually typically the lowest
it's sometimes by a factor of two or
three X so and it's gonna be the fees
will be very low v that we charge will
be very low so then the the users gets
most of most of the rewards that they
they're supposed to get so I think yeah
I do hope that you will become sort of
our major players in the space yeah
that's a really kind of important
strategic decision maybe elaborate on
that a little bit right it's almost like
kind of the Amazon approach of hey let's
deliver as much back to the user or
customer as possible and then they'll
stay with us for a long period of time
obviously a lot of your competitors are
charging higher fees and and kind of
extracting more value why did you choose
to go with the low fee model and then
kind of how is that thought process
changed over time sure I think that's
just a number of factors there's a
mentality factor of the different
founders how much do they believe in
this industry whether they're short-term
a long term and then there's the skill
that we already have or people already
have so to be honest when we first start
the go is just distal eyes right so just
to get to cash flow breakeven and be
able to survive and potentially if we're
not there yet then we may want to take a
little bit of risk and then I also get
gets rewarded later on so initially if
that's my thought process and once you
go over that herd always like well now
the mentality really comes into play
it's quite to be honest and once the
other like a reasonable exchange
learning you have like decent number of
users etc it's not that hard to make
some money I mean yeah you won't be able
to it make some money but then as most
platforms or most businesses the more
you charge the slower you grow and the
the more you charge you may even you may
even like actually have a short-term
business the uncertainty in this in this
industry also causes people to be more
short-sighted for example if you
establish an exchange in a country and
the regulations change every three
months then you're kind of forced to be
more short-sighted and just sort of look
let's let's make as much money as we can
as quickly as possible and then when
things change which is pack up well or
at least we cover our investments but I
think I've always I've been in the in
the industry for a long time even before
finance so I haven't have a much longer
term play I believe quit will be they
will be the super future like if you
look at 10th
50 years 100 years from now so I have a
much longer vision on this and luckily
we got over the bump for the sort of
survival mode very quickly like within a
few months and it was also within those
first few months like even with the
first quarter after we launched the
platform we seemed like some of the
regulations change in China that
impacted us quite severely but actually
afterwards looking back it was actually
a very positive influence we actually
drove a lot of users to us but at the
time it was like quite tricky so we we
got we've gone through the initial sort
of phases very quickly and right now we
have a platform that's that has scale
and we have we have the brand and I
think what I think right now we have a
much longer I have a much longer term
sort of play I just want to be able to
service users for the next 20 50 100
years hopefully so yeah so for us it's
really not about making soap making all
the money right now so businesses very
often have to have to decide between
short-term profits versus long-term
gains for us everything from for us
everything's long-term so this is why
we're still investing in large company
in large deals in this environment it's
not about the next three months it's not
about the next year it's like more than
that so and also we're not a publicly
listed company so we don't have this
sort of Wall Street analyst calls etc we
do have a token by the tokens getting
more and more district to centralize and
tokens to be fine but so I think so I
think basically we are we have a pistol
mentality aspect of this is really
important so for this reason we we
really want to protect our users with
the review our users much much more than
our short-term revenue so we do make
money we make money very transparently
people trade so that's pretty much it
really yeah yeah you mentioned a public
company any interest in ever going
public or your do you enjoy being a
private company with without all of the
these short-term pressures yeah so I
don't I don't think we're going public
anytime soon
we're not preparing for it we're not
prepared for it so we're kind of running
the company you know in direction that's
not really fit for I feel
so a lot a lot of the decisions we make
sort of very fundamentally shape shapes
of the organization I know you may use
the word company that month got often so
it's kind of hard to IPO that kind of
the IPO the IPO will doesn't really fit
our type of organization which is
totally which is very decentralized and
I also don't believe in the IPO game I
think that games really weigh out the
system really broken basically the
entrepreneurs are no longer number one
the entrepreneurs are no longer making
the money they they basically have to
yield TVC is very early on to be able to
grow a large platform because to core a
platform you do need to have it you do
need heavy investments and typically
entrepreneurs have the skills may or may
not have the skills but they don't have
the money and when the institutional
investors come in when the VCS come in
they want returns that they like to be
honest very few leases care about their
vision most guys will care about the
vision will be building stuff themselves
there's very few that do care about the
visions I don't want to like I don't
want to like often everybody but but
most mostly VCS have a have a fund that
have a that have like a fixed returns
they need to run that they need to raise
the next fund etc and they actually want
to have pressure to sort of a cash out
and that they want to run the firm's to
IPO and then when the firm's IPO the VC
the CEOs are typically giving a mandate
you get the price to a certain point and
they usually have a deal
and then the CEOs get a bonus when they
get to that point the lease is cash out
at that point and then the retails the
you tell you nesters get left holding
the bag and hopefully if the company
does well in the future great but
there's a lot of risks there but
everybody knows how to play that game so
that this is why the CEOs gets a lot of
money this is why the VCS structures
deals that way
I don't think super beneficial I think
there's a better structure that can be
achieved we have a lot more freedom we
are we are luckily we are we are
cashflow positive and we can dictate our
own growth at the rate we grow at we can
fund relatively
mute ideas sometimes some really wild
ideas some so we're kind of already as a
start-up but also as a investment arm
and we have a lot of experiments going
on so we have a lot of freedom to try
this kind of stuff and we have a very
United team so we don't we don't have a
board telling us what to do etc so so I
think yeah I don't I don't see the need
to do IPO and also given the regulatory
uncertainty in manager restrictions it's
you're unclear to see how a crypto
currency exchanges on IPO so we prefer
to let probably less somebody else do
that first and we we don't we don't need
to be the first one there yeah it brings
up B&B which I think there's a lot of
folks you know think multi coin but you
know once these people have kind of
written these long analysis on the idea
that B&B if you don't go the IPO route
can serve as a way to really drive kind
of shareholder value but in this unique
new model maybe talk a little bit about
where B&B is today and then kind of how
you see that evolving over time sure I
think we structure B&B is very much a
bit illicit token so isn't it does not
represent security in - stop being
balanced or any of the - affiliated
entities
it's a freely traded coin that we used
to we used to we use my CEO back in 2017
to raise some funds to bootstrap the
platform and then from there I think
today is grown about 130 X from in the
last two years and the peak is growing
about 400 X but you know those
fluctuations and there's this common
discussion between what's the difference
between shares and their token so now
that's a pretty interesting dynamic so I
think the shares and tokens could be
separate but especially if you want to
if you said look the tokens are used in
that in our ecosystem for like let's not
use my finance let's use like say a
gaming company right so you issue a
token people can use used it to pay for
I don't know can eat virtual merchandise
like so then that you use that in the
game and then you have the company
shares that you can sort of the company
shares are worth however much you can
look at the income profits etc of the
company and determine the price of that
where we have chosen not to well at
least for now we're not you sort of
monetize the shares aspects of Finance
so the and right now so we don't we
don't see a need for it right now and a
lot of companies stay private
even like if you look at Bloomberg
Bloomberg company is still private it's
a valuable company but Bloomberg makes
money from profits so he didn't really
sell a lot of shares to make money so I
think right now our focus really just
and I think right now if we say we
launch my way issue like - shares and
raise a lot of money and continue to do
that you actually dilute some of the
value in the B&B ecosystem so we
actually just want to say look we will
continue to push B and B to be used
anymore across our ecosystem and also
you are at partners ecosystems and
that's what we can also be focused on
and we're now gonna mana so I'm at least
right now I'm not really thinking about
monetizing the shares at all actually I
would I haven't I have an idea which I
don't talk to people asking about I
eventually want to make finance a real
deal like a real decentralized
autonomous operation and if we do that
then we want to consider once the things
we will have to do is we will likely
have to forego the valuable shares so
okay so you got to explain you gotta
explain this a little bit because this
is I think kind of the extreme end of
the non IPO path which is you
essentially decentralize the entire
thing and you being the founder it's a
big financial decision because you
basically would say the equity in what
I've built is going to be worth zero
you're not gonna have the payday from
the equity and you now have this Dow but
if you have the cash flow there's
obviously value there maybe talk through
exactly like what would that world look
like and then what would that mean for
you and the rest of the team sure I
actually don't know what that word would
look like to be honest we kind of this
is new territory right so we were kind
of experimenting ourselves and so we're
kind of working territory we just landed
on this land and we're still exploring
we can see there's a forest but we don't
know what's in the forest we can see
there's a hill we don't know what's
behind it kind of thing so in my mind
would kind of leave that terror
in terms of organizational structure etc
we do have team members who have eso PS
we do have we still do have a couple
external shareholders and so and so this
aspect is it is a it is an interesting
topic to sort of explore and discuss but
I do think a company who has very well I
would have said yeah I would say
organization who have very strong cash
flow are able to take care of their
employees shareholders etc so the
different ways to monetize and this is
why heist into the long term play that
that we have I mean you can say or
shares and well basically the shares
encompass future value right so the
value of the shares of a company
encompass how much money can be made
later on
whereas if you just do a dividend or
profit split to just how much money
we've earned so far but if you but if
you take a longer version say look the
ich there there are many companies who
does not who does not go IPO that many
founders who like again taking Bloomberg
for example like I'm the guy's really
rich and he has a I think he still owns
20% of the shares of the company and the
never really saw their name anything
else
Merrill Lynch was well formed a masters
probably still yes or the probably
change hands because Merrill may have
may have had its own financial issues
but so in that in that aspect I think
there's I think as long as you get
investors and he kept team members would
eat into the same vision we're here for
the long term play then that's less of a
problem we actually looked at a new idea
that which I think we invented actually
so I named it and so I named it and then
a our team kind of is polishing it we
call eg okey so instead an employee
stock option we call it employee token
options we actually don't like the word
employee we call them team members but
in WTOP its kind cheesy but overall
though we want to say look of our
profits we can distribute some to inc
tokens to our team members and the
tokens i
interesting because the tokens value
fluctuates with how well the ecosystems
doing and and if and in this way the
team members are incentivized to sort of
a koala ecosystem not just a corporate
value not just like not not just an
enterprise value but more of these sort
of echo system and I think that that's
much that's actually more line with what
we want to achieve right now we want to
build good out of the ecosystem we
wanted to centralize sort of the the the
enterprise aspect of it even though
right now I think banners calm
especially the trading platforms do is a
large revenue generator but things could
check like we have a text it's not a
super big right now but if ok thanks for
changing three years five years so weeks
we are experimenting with that and I
think super fascinating and but if you
ask me like look what's the blueprint is
a hundred percent gonna go this way
I don't really know to be honest because
is overton territory we're experimenting
and we may make some mistakes and we
have to readjust but we are exploring
with the team together so and I think
whatever we wherever we find out that
works very happy to share with the
community and hopefully other
organization will be able to follow -
unique yeah - is unique in this ways we
actually started as more centralized
organization which pushing this way
whereas other like projects like
aetherium they did start much more
decentralized so it's a bit different
yeah yeah it's really interesting
because basically what you're talking
about like what is equity right equities
a claim on cash flows to claim on and
company's assets and then obviously kind
of an option on future profits etc
really what you're talking about here is
like a lot of that is more speculative
in nature because you're you're looking
into the future but if you've actually
built a business that works that has
cash flow except really now you say to
people as well if you're a critical
investor or whole you know equity holder
if you will really what you're just
doing is you're getting a percent of
profits right if that's paid out except
you know it changes the dynamic and then
obviously if you're an employee would
you rather have something that
represents you know potential future
performance or would you rather have a
percent of profits today I think most
employees actually what I want you know
percent of profits today
it's better short term in - it's much
more tangent
in many cases yeah I think the the the
and also there's a very subtle
difference between profits of a
traditional organization profits of a
crypt organization so in crypto even if
our profits are a b and b today let's
say we distribute and beat you some of
our team members or BTC there's an
implied gross value of that profit even
afterwards so it's so it's not like okay
no I I received a hundred dollars and
that's it the dollar was only devalued
so there's even after them receive the
profits because it's given mostly in
tokens and actually a large number to
hold it and they'd only sell they are in
a line with a with sort of overall
ecosystem cross not just a company
growth so they are aligned to sort of
look let's get the bra a brave rather
deal let's get more partnerships to grow
the ecosystem which actually works
really really well for us which is
totally aligned with what I think we
should be doing yeah a little bit one of
the other questions that a lot of people
have was around security tokens which I
think it's related here kind of what are
you seeing in the security token world
and is that something that finance
whatever kind of dip their toe into sure
I think there's a lot of potential in
the security tokens world but I but
honestly though I think most of the
implementations today are too restricted
so most of the implementations today is
just taking the piece of paper that was
not used to represent a security and put
it on the blockchain and on the
blockchain I've seen a lot of the
implementations where on the smart smart
contracts has a wide list of addresses
that you can send people to that kind of
defeats the purpose of blocks and izing
it it doesn't have the freedom that you
can send it to anybody anywhere in the
world etc so and
to be honest I don't feel that we have
so much issue with that piece of paper
very few people are forging it there's
very easy ways to to teaches or verify
that piece of paper actually represents
shares in a company so I think most of
the most of the implementations I've
seen so far are relatively new team
entry and they don't solve the
fundamental problem of actually having a
security token on the blockchain it's
really traded around the world anybody
can participate that kind of stuff that
would require I think a lot of
regulatory changes so it's not just it I
think the technology is there for
but the regulatory hurdles in different
countries are are not solved
I actually think actually I'm guessing
on this front again I could be wrong
because this is kind of guess into the
future
I think the countries were less
developed in the security space will
actually be easier to change because
like if you take a country like United
States there's so many securities laws
changing all of them it's just a big
like it's a big train that's already
moving in one direction it's gonna be
difficult to change that in a different
direction whereas in countries where the
securities market is not super developed
they may want to jumpstart their
securities markets and what we have seen
is actually many countries want to
securitize that real-estate they want to
securitize their company so that they
can raise money internationally so for
countries that that's less developed
that's they actually want the money to
go to that country and they don't want
ylist in smart contracts they don't want
like all of these restrictions so I
think things gonna play different play
out differently I think the market size
is a huge like we can all see that how
much of that size is gonna cover right
ready to crypto I think what you see our
position is basically look we we keep we
do monitor that the space we are
interested in it there's already a few
early players who are sort of plowing
the way pushing it and we'll just see
how they do and if they do well we can
partner with them to some extent we can
copy them and we can innovate so all
those options are open and but for the
sto specifically - France is not in
dealing with regulators so we don't have
to wait like I don't have a lawyer
background we don't have team as lawyers
chasing different regulators etc I think
there are people who are who have those
backgrounds who are much more fitted
into chasing those type of businesses
hopefully those guys will make some
leeway and then in if they do then we
have a technology platform if they want
to partner with us we more than happy to
partner we're banners cloud we can we
can deploy a separate exchange so we we
typically is a technology
providing just aspect yeah I love it
makes a lot of sense last question for
you somebody asked what is the biggest
misconception that people have of you
what's the one thing that maybe people
think about cz and and you would say
they're either wrong or don't have kind
of the truth on that's a great shot
it's a very simple way actually a lot of
people think I control the
cryptocurrency price so much easier like
Bitcoin would be going straight up and
then so I think that I think one of the
biggest misconceptions is like a CZ pump
it like what what do you expect me to do
I don't have okay so so that's a I think
I think fundamentally there's a lot of
misconception that thinking the biggest
change is control price we don't we
don't trade like I can't tell you which
way the price is gonna go if I could the
price will be way higher right now so I
actually yeah I'm always bullish I
always think the price is too low and
for our business the price is much
better it's much better for the price to
be higher so I think that's definitely
one of the misconceptions people have
and I'm personally I'm a very poor
trader I try this like ten years like a
decade ago and didn't work too well I
learned that very early on so I'm a
technology builder and we provide
platforms to you for people to access
liquidity so I think that's one of the
biggest misconceptions that people have
they think that we actually influence
price we don't I really wish we could
but we don't I can speak for you in that
if cz controlled price Bitcoin would be
at hundreds of thousands of dollars for
sure for sure
awesome man well listen I appreciate you
taking the time to do this you know I
think that a lot of people are obviously
paying attention to what you guys are
building and you're really pushing the
pace of innovation so keep it up and
left is again in the future
absolutely yeah thanks for thanks for
all the things that you do in the
industry yeah I mean we talk to each
other on Twitter all the time but I
really appreciate what you're doing as
well which is like this distributing
high-quality information and always
pushing the industry forward so yeah I
appreciate it and I'm sure we'll talk
again soon